presque quarante mille cas confirmés en
seulement 24 heures la situation
sanitaire dégénère en inde alors que le
pays a annoncé vendredi avoir franchi le
million de cas de malades du coït 19
dimanche les autorités ont fait part du
nombre le plus élevé de cas quotidiens
déclaré et ce bilan serait très
nettement sous-estimé selon de nombreux
experts qui estiment qu'il pourrait être
20 à 30 fois supérieure pourtant
certains médecins restent confiants pour
eux les cas serait plus facile à
identifier dans les petites villes et
dans les zones rurales
je suis beaucoup plus confiant
concernant l'identification des
personnes atteintes ducobu 19 elles se
rendent dans les petits endroits en
particulier les villages en raison d'une
identification rapide de ces cas est du
fait que pratiquement tout le monde se
connaît en ce qui concerne notre réponse
le département de la santé ainsi que
celui de l'éducation médicale sont en
alerte avec notamment les bases de
données quant à la surveillance elle se
poursuit et je suis très confiant dans
le fait qu'à partir du moment où les
choses sont connues
nous mettons en place une surveillance
très resserré ce constat alarmant
survient au moment où plusieurs états
indiens impose des mesures de
confinement ont ciblé pour tenter
d'endiguer l'épidémie le gouvernement
devrait en faire davantage et prendre
des mesures adéquates pour réduire le
nombre de cas le gouvernement travaille
sur ce point mais devrait en faire plus
que ce qu'il fait c'est la saison de la
mousson et pendant les pluies il ya de
fortes chances que les cas augmentent
veiller à sa propre sécurité doivent
être en sécurité ce protégé chez eux
lui nous maintenant une distance sociale
plus vite le coït 19 quittera notre
société
près d'une douzaine d'états ont déjà
imposé des restrictions sur les zones de
confinement des
une qui peuvent être aussi petit que
quelques maisons ou une rue en parallèle
les gouvernements locaux tentent de
maintenir les économies locales en
déployant notamment de petits centres de
détention pour éviter que le virus
circule librement